we have seen that rational numbers
comprise of terminating decimals and
non-terminating recurring decimals
in this video we will see how we can
convert a decimal number to the rational
form p by q
when we are given p by q we can divide p
by q to get a decimal number
but to convert a decimal number into the
form p by q is a little more interesting
let's look at this conversion first
terminating decimal to the form p by q
so let's look at our first example
0.45
there's only one thing you need to
observe here
it's the digits after the decimal point
in this case we have four and five
two digits after the decimal point
this was the most important step
once we find this we write the number
without the decimal
in this case it's zero four five
we write it without the decimal point
and divided by some power of 10
and what will be the power of this 10 in
the denominator
yes it will be the number of digits
after the decimal point which is 2 in
this case
this is actually 45
so 0.45
can be written as 45 divided by 10
squared
which can be written as 45 by 100
there's our answer it's in the p by q
form
this answer is not incorrect but it's
not complete
we have to reduce it to its simplest
form
5 multiplied by 9 equals 45
and 5 multiplied by 20 equals one
hundred
this equals nine by twenty
this is the answer since it's in the
simplest form
zero point four five was written as nine
by twenty
all we had to observe was the number of
digits after the decimal point
here's another example
2.225
it has three digits after the decimal
point
so first we write the number without the
decimal
it will be 2 2 2 5
and divided by 10 raised to 3
we write 3 as the power of 10 since we
have 3 digits after the decimal point
and that will equal 2 2225 by 1000
and this can be reduced to 89 by 40.
so we wrote
2.225 as 89 by 40.
that was simple
but what if you're asked to write
2.225 as a mixed fraction
a mixed fraction is something like 3 1
by 4.
it means 3 and a quarter
3 is called the whole part and 1 by 4 is
called the fractional part
so how do we get this decimal form in
this mixed fraction form
it's very simple the whole part is the
number to the left of the decimal point
2 becomes the whole part
the numerator of the fractional part is
the number to the right of the decimal
point it's 225
and guess what the denominator of the
fractional part is the same as the
denominator in the previous case
10 raised to 3. again the power of 10 is
equal to the number of digits after the
decimal point
that's it now we just have to simplify
the fractional part to its simplest form
this can be written as 2 225 by 1000
this is the whole part and this is the
fractional part
this when reduced gives us 9 by 40.
so 2.225 can be written as 2 9 by 40.
that becomes a mixed fraction form
just to check your answer it's always
recommended that you convert this into a
normal fraction and verify
this would equal 2 multiplied by 40 plus
9 by 40
that would equal 80 plus 9 by 40 which
equals 89 by 40.
same as the answer we got earlier
while converting it into a mixed
fraction just remember that the number
to the left of the decimal will be the
whole part and the number to the right
of the decimal will be the numerator of
the fractional part the denominator in
both the cases is the same
10 raised to the number of digits after
the decimal place
you